[Music]
good afternoon guys today we're going to
just be moving cows but but really why
we're moving cows I'm just gonna kind of
tell you about rotational grazing and
what we do here compared to what some
farmers do around this area also tell
you why we rotational grazing tense of
graze and really the purpose of it you
know for the longest you've always heard
especially big cattlemen say it's
impossible to have a cow unless you have
acre per cow or two acres per cow and if
you're running a big farm and you're you
don't have a lot of cross fencing or do
some kind of rotational grazing plan
that is very that is true however if you
learn to manage your your your grass and
manage your paddocks the right way a lot
of times you can take that that plan and
put a lot more cows in a certain area we
have about 35 to 36 acres in front of
our house and to be honest with you we
don't use it you can see all over there
it's all pines in front of house so it's
a pine thicket if we needed it you know
we could cut it I guess but we really
don't need it we have five head of
cattle and we run through six rotational
grazing paddocks now I want to walk you
through the packs we have because we're
going to be moving them off so you'll
see what they've done to one paddock and
how we allow it to heal for for about
five to six weeks and then we'll they'll
be back on it but you see how it'll grow
great so let's start off with um kind of
where we're gonna move them so as you
look right here you see it's just piles
of grass all through this little paddock
now this paddock is not big enough for
three or four or five cows probably not
even really big enough for two cows to
stay full-time but that's not what we do
and when you talk about rotational
grazing the whole purpose of rotational
grazing is you're gonna take this little
paddock and put them in it for a while
and then you're gonna move it to this
one now you see this one is more
splotchy it's got some grass but it's
really not where it needs to be well
this is the paddock that they came out
of before we moved them across to the
other side of house so this
the third week of it healing now the
grass that's here is is a winter grass
that's kind of leaving from here but
you'll start seeing you can see some of
the clover and you see some of the
really some Bermuda and Scott some old
field behavior growing back up in here
but it's not ready to put cows back on
so what we do is we will let it heal for
about another three weeks and then by
then this field will really look like
that feel but it's because we're
allowing it to heal you know here here
we are we have cows who are who are not
tearing the grass up but we're letting
them eat the grass and then ultimately
they're they're fertilizing the grass
because they're using the restroom here
and have them fresh manure and as it
just sits here and the rainfalls ends up
making a great paddock so we'll move
them into this pack now so we've got
this one here that's about three weeks
from healing they will stay in that
paddock they're the pretty one for about
a week to week and a half however long
it takes them to eat it
now here's the pros and cons to
intensive grazing or rotational grazing
or whatever you want to call it a lot of
that grass there is beautiful grass some
of us winter grass some of it spring
grass coming back through pros when you
put them in a place like that they have
to eat with what's there meaning they're
not gonna pick and choose when when you
don't have cross fencing or you don't
have an intensive grazing plans and you
let cows just go because hey you have
enough acreage for the cow
it's just like us when we're at a
potluck or a buffet we may all this food
may be okay for us to eat ultimately we
may pick and choose what we want to eat
so what what anticip grazing does is it
says not only do you eat the good the
good grass and the high-protein grass
we're gonna make you eat kind of the
junk grass or some of the older grass
too if you don't make them eat it
they're not gonna eat it so then you
have fields growing with a lot more
weeds with a lot more mature grasses
that are no good for them so what we do
is when we put them in this and you'll
see on this other side we normally don't
split our herd however we have split our
herd this last few weeks because we're
trying to get one of our cows bred with
a bowl so we've got a bowl with a cow
and then the other three are in another
paddock which I don't even like
but in this case we are trying to breed
her but but what we're going to do is
we'll put them in here and if they
they'll eat all this rye grass real
quick because it's a winter grass it's
beautiful it's got heavy protein but
some of this new grass is coming up I
see some red clover and and even some
junk grass they may not want to eat it
however if we leave them here they
really kind of have to eat it now does
that mean no because ultimate they're
gonna get their nutrients and they're
gonna have hay and things like that but
what it does is it makes all the grass
maintain one level and that's what we
want so once they finish that they'll
move to the next now let me kind of get
you over here if you look in this field
over here across the little gravel drive
now that that grass right there it has a
lot of weeds in it it's got some good
summer grass growing through it looks
like a lot of behavior that's starting
to come up you can see the sprigs now I
did not plant that in rye grass
whatsoever so it's never had winter
grass
so as these grasses here start dying and
they start healing and trying to grow
summer grass I've got this paddock over
here that has not been touched that's a
pretty nice paddock but then all behind
it if you look on the other side of
these this fence but before you get to
the pond we'll have temporary fencing
hot wire fencing like poly wire fencing
up and then we will do the same plant so
we will make another rotation on
temporary fencing while all this other
ground heals now the reason I say all of
that is to say when people tell you you
can't have enough you can't have cows on
a smaller piece of land you can you just
got to learn how many is too many but
then you need to learn how to control
your grass a wise man once told me that
you know when your cattle farm you're
actually a grass farmer and that is so
true and look I'm no expert I'm trying
to learn as I go but ultimately if you
get them on a good paddock rotation and
you make them eat the the paddock that
they're in ultimately it's gonna help
them thrive you're not gonna have to do
a lot of supplement feeding and you can
have a few more cows than you thought
you could have had now cons I mean one
of the cons right now or was a few weeks
ago with rotational grazing
it's got to be perfect weather well
there's no such thing as perfect weather
now when in the south of Mississippi we
had about four or five weeks of just
just rain I mean just rained and rained
and rained and rain and of course I know
it's for a purpose but what it did is
the paddock they were in they pretty
much destroyed just because they were
they were slopping around in the mud it
hurt the ground because the grass quit
growing in those areas that they were on
so what what we did was we had to
supplement a lot more hay now we have
hay and we're happy to give them hay
however we were giving them a lot more
hay because the grounds tore up so that
paddock now had to heal a lot longer so
ultimately then it allow it so that
feels hurt then we had to move into
another field that we kind of had to
hold them in for a little bit so they
wouldn't tear up any other fields so a
con to making sure rotational grazing
works is weather when the natural
elements happens you've got to be
prepared to either supplement with the
hay and have the hand accessible or be
willing to put them in a paddock and
kind of let it get hurt a little bit
until that other one kind of grows back
so it's a learning curve but like I said
I messed up probably one paddock that
took me a little bit more time to heal
it now I'll show you that paddock
because this is fine now but um so
elements can hurt it so if you have
droughts that grass for those patran are
gonna grow as quick so it's important to
have maybe like I had like I was showing
you back here those paddocks that have
not had rye grass on them and they have
not been disturbed at all so say for
instance I get a drought or I get major
weather and it's stead of tearing up my
paddocks that has fertile ground and
seed that's already in it I may put them
in poly wire out in the middle over
there just to get them off this land to
let it heal
so the good thing about digital grazing
is it can it can help your land and make
it more fertile however if you abuse
that it can really hurt your land
because if you leave them too long on
this paddock instead I haven't grass at
two or three inches you have dirt
because they've ate it all so make sure
you're taking care of rotational grazing
and making sure they're eating but don't
let them eat it to the ground because it
won't grow back nearly as fast so again
this is where we're moving them
all right summer over there that's why
we will move on why these heal one they
came out of about two or three weeks ago
so you see it's it's it's a lot more
dirt a lot the grass is not growing
heavy and all the areas yet but it will
come back but we've got another three
weeks of healing so let's go look at the
other side if you remember my aspiring
bull rider that I brought the bull over
and you saw the video of him going crazy
after that we say you know what we may
want to figure something out because we
have some young casts and also a ball
and with our kids out we want to make
sure they're safe and make sure the ball
don't get away or either the little
casket away so we built this we got a
guy that was a good friend of ours build
this uh this run basically it's like a
true cattle run so it's it's it's gonna
be a way that we can get from paddock to
paddock and still be in a closed system
we have one little angus who I tell you
he's a handful he will not listen he's
stubborn he's actually a very smart you
know
bull but he won't listen he won't get
close to us so this little walk instead
of us having to put him in a trailer our
chance walking him and all sudden
something happening to him or he gets in
the woods and we got tried track him
down we built this little walkway
through so you see look at this how cool
it is it's awesome so at least to the
other three paddocks and so basically
we're gonna go look at those and now
here's another thing I have three dairy
cows or actually two dairy cow and a
deer bull when we talk about grazing and
we talked about homesteading a lot of
times we most home stores will have
dairy animals well if you're doing
paddocks remember their animals need a
lot more grass and a lot more food a lot
more substance than sometimes even meat
cows or meat goats and the reason being
is because hey they're giving you a lot
of milk this is water they're nutrients
but luckily you want to do is drain them
so you have to watch your cows to make
sure they're getting enough nutrients
but if you do a good intense cruising
plan they won't matter if their dairy
won't matter if they're beat but it will
they all do fine okay let me show you
this
this is our dairy field as you see we
have a stanchion right there now my
daeryuk health that I'm milking Elsa
stays in these fields these two paddocks
just because it makes it easier for us
to have her here now most of the time
I'll put the cows with her and then
she's the only one that kind of stays
back but as you can see over here in the
far corner right there
we've got her with with our bull because
again we were trying to breed her back
she had a calf in January so now as we
get closer to April she's starting to
come back and heat she could have been
bred this last time but I don't know I
didn't see it so we're putting them back
together now let me show these two
paddocks this paddock here you see it
looks like I've cut grass you see if
they've taken it down to Harley nothing
still grass not dirt because we don't
want dirt showing but you see how they
have maintained it now so that means
they're ready to move so now this one
this field right here will have about a
five and a half to six and a half week
healing process on that land now I've
got rye that they pretty much ate which
is a winter grass and fall grass my
spring grass is all starting to really
come back up in this field so now it
will have six weeks of growth and
healing that's awesome so again intense
crazing we want to make sure they're
eating everything now let's talk about
this paddock you see I don't know if you
tell by the video there's some grass
that's getting a little thicker that's
growing better here I'll show you some
let's look you see you see these little
I'm sorry it's windy so excuse the noise
and also the movement home but you see
it's starting to grow right here in the
middle this is the dairy field we only
bring her in to eat and then we bring
the bull in with her when I do milker
but ultimately they were here about two
weeks ago too so they were over there
three weeks ago over here two weeks ago
so you see this one's a little bit
behind that one over there so again this
one's still got about four weeks for it
so they're going they jump back and
forth and it is you got to make sure you
you remember where they were and make
sure you have a good plan because
ultimately you don't want to skip a
field and all sudden you you heard
another field and abused it because
they've been there too long or you heard
another field because of the rain look
right here see that dirt that is that's
that's the passage between this gate
yeah I told you the bad rain of the that
came for about five weeks this was the
field they heard now as you see it's
healing it's healing all next to the
barn but right here under me it needs
some help you see some sprinkling grass
starting to grow but they've heard it
now there's nothing we can do it was
rain so that's one they actually have
not been in here and won't be in here
really for another four weeks we'll see
how it goes I may even bring a disc in
here disc it up lightly and put a little
extra seat in here just to make sure
it's gonna thrive we try not to have any
kind of fertilizers unless they're
they're natural and organic
we do have an organic fertilizer we
can't throw out we just choose not to
again because our dairy cows eating this
grass and turn around we're milking
nurse I'd rather not do that if we don't
have to but but you see where they're at
the grass is down so we're going to go
ahead and take them out of this field
and we'll take them across to the other
side now as I said I true I really don't
like splitting our herd however since
I'm milking her and also I'm trying to
breed her with our bull we've allowed
them to stay away from the Angus and the
other two jerseys or other Jersey excuse
me
the other Jersey is bred she is a
beautiful little Jersey she's my
low-lying Jersey and hopefully the one
will start milking by the year in when
she casts but she's a beautiful
first-time heifer and and she's on the
other side with the anguses but I'm
going to show you their fields because
they're being very choosy they're not
eating on the grass they're supposed to
be eating so guess what I'm gonna leave
them there probably for another at least
3 to 4 days to make them eat the grass
that they may not want to eat and the
whole purpose of that is just to make
sure they're taken care of because it
guess what if you leave it what's gonna
happen is either I'm gonna have to bush
hog the junk down or either it's gonna
have hey buddy
hey buddy
he always wants to rub it here but if
you don't let them eat it you're going
to mature grass well guess what they
want fresh good immature grass to eat
they don't want this big thick kudzu
style weeds and heavy grass so I'm gonna
make them eat it because if they don't
that means they're gonna be more weeds
over there that means I'm gonna have to
get in there with some kind of disc or
bush hog and there's no purpose because
there's a good grass for them to eat so
let's go look at it right quick all
right now we're at the other paddock
it's a get to where we're at eight they
meet up across our roads that's where
the two cows are for the paddock they're
in right now the paddock they were in
which is the dairy barn side and then
basically on the other side of the house
right here is where that that little
crossover is so we'll go over there and
take all the cows from these fields over
that crossover and get them to the other
fields but let me show you this field
now do you see how they've taken some
grass down but not all of it it's kind
of patchy now I'm gonna make them stay
here for a little bit longer but
ultimately they need to they need to eat
this grass and that way when this heals
back up this field look great so this
again once I hey girl hey girl so again
once this field and once we move them
completely out of here once these come
over to the other side probably the next
three or four days with the ball and
with them the milking cow this this
field baseball except for another five
to six weeks so it will heal back up
with no problem now you see the taller
grasses some of the winter grasses left
and there are some weeds in there too
but the shorter grass is where they've
already ate but we're already starting
to see some spring grass Pro back
through so that's another thing about
the cons of this time of year of
paddocks here in the mid season going
from spring going to spring from winner
are either coming out of summer going
into
all kind of go into winter when you're
planting your ride you got to make sure
they're still on some good summer grass
or either they have some hay again
coming out of winter rise gonna start
dying especially if we have some hot
days and so that spring grass may not be
coming up because we may still have some
frosty nights so you got to make sure
that you're leaving some grass that's
untouched start out making sure you have
a good bit of supplement hay and then
that way you're taking care of them
while you're going through these seasons
as well so as you see we've got the
little anguses the and of course the
Jersey Ally this is the one that we know
is bred
she is probably three two or three
months bred and she's looking she's a
just a beautiful beautiful church she's
a low-lying Jersey then we have the two
anguses then we have of course that EO
is a registered miniature New Jersey and
then of course Elsa is a full-size
Jersey alright I hope you've learned a
little bit again the pros and cons to
rotational grazing we love it it allows
us to have cows if we put all these
fields together we'd have enough
probably for the cows but ultimately you
would not be able to control and they
would pick and choose what they wanted
to eat so then we'd be wasting a whole
lot of grass and really it would kind of
hurt the ground cuz ultimately they'd be
all over it when you put them in a place
even if you use poly wire fencing poly
tape fencing wire hot wire fencing are
either true barbed wire it's good to
make them stay in one spot eat it down
and then move it over
don't let them up use the ground but let
them eat it and then move them over
because ultimately it's gonna help your
head will stay fertile and keep it going
hope this videos been good thank you
happy homesteading y'all
you